questo top
intanto è dedicato alle donne come avete
capito stalla introduzione premetto di
essere un grande sostenitore della
meritocrazia e contemporaneamente
premetto di essere anche un sostenitore
della parità tra donne e uomini su tutto
in particolare ho avuto l'esperienza di
lavorare per brani internazionali per
tanti anni e di conoscere donne manager
e donne top manager veramente
straordinario il problema è che ai miei
occhi non risultavano solo straordinari
risultavano dei giganti perché si
muovevano in dei mondi che erano
totalmente maschili o quasi totalmente
maschile soprattutto i mondi che
frequentavo io che erano quelli diciamo
della innovazione attraverso la
tecnologia donna dal latino domina
significa signora che sempre dal latino
segno revoca la nobiltà d'animo mentre
uomo dal latino e significa terra e
partendo proprio dalla terra
l'agricoltura ormai l'uomo automatizzata
le abitazioni le riscaldata il trasporto
pesante là delle catture veicoli e la
cacciagione la compriamo ormai al
supermercato
gli storici identificano la dominanza
maschile con la conquista e la
protezione della proprietà privata
attraverso la forza ma oggi la proprietà
è sempre più garantita dagli stati dalle
leggi ed è riconosciuta ormai è la pace
si sta dimostrando e lo vediamo dalla
dallo scenario socio politico mondiale
più profittevole della guerra quindi la
funzione strumentale del marchio sta per
caso venendo meno
no panic cari amici maschi
non siamo ancora inutili ma siamo
sicuramente un po meno utili
storicamente l'innovazione tecnologica
creato tanto lavoro tutte le volte viene
realizzato un nuovo strumento si
aprivano nuovi posti di lavoro ma per la
prima volta un nuovo strumento che è
stato inventato dall'uomo non compete
con strumenti esistenti ma compete
direttamente con l'intelligenza e
l'apprendimento male si parla delle
artificial intelligence oggi è
inevitabile certamente tutti nei
cellulari e contribuirà alla crescita
dell'economia
da qui al 2030 per 15.7 trilioni di
dollari potenziando principalmente due
cose la personalizzazione dei servizi e
dei prodotti e la produttività della
zero
non parliamo quindi più di macchine che
giocano a scacchi ma parliamo di
macchine che sono in grado di lavorare
al posto nostro in ambiti specifici
perché la artificial intelligence potrà
essere un'opportunità di riscatto e
leadership dunque che le donne devono
afferrare il mondo del lavoro e quale
sarà il nuovo ruolo della donna
questa ragazza si chiama bambina era una
bimba nel 2014 si chiama dakota ed è
stata protagonista di una campagna
pubblicitaria globale che si chiamava
laica di donare la contro gli stereotipi
di genere e ha dato il via ad una
sensibilizzazione sul tema molto forte
che partita dal basso partita dai social
ed è stata abbracciata da diversi
istituti di ricerca tra i quali nel 2017
l'istitute for learning and brain
science della university of washington i
quali hanno raccolto 100 bambini
dell'età di sei anni maschi e femmine
qualmente distribuiti e li hanno divisi
in tre gruppi un gruppo che gioca con
gli animali robot un gruppo che racconta
la storia con un altro gruppo che
giocava liberamente quello che è
successo e che dopo settimane di test li
hanno intervistati e le interviste sono
su youtube sono molto molto si batte e
quello che emerso è che le materie
sempre materie scientifiche science
technology e signorine mas ragazze e
ragazzi hanno lo stesso potere di
apprendimento la stessa capacità di
essere intelligente
ed è proprio da lì che partiamo
intelligenza nel dall'ati noi
dentro leggere che vuol dire comprendere
quindi comprendere a fondo e
l'apprendimento si basa su tre
dimensioni
la dimensione del dato che forniamo ai
bambini ma anche a noi stessi adulti il
contesto in cui si dedicano e
l'esperienza sensoriale per esempio se
si viene spiegato che un albero è
composto da radici tronco foglie ram e
poi ci vengono fornite delle foto il
solo di alberi di colore blu
e poi noi andiamo a fare una passeggiata
in giro e vediamo che gli alberi sono
verbi correggiamo il tiro nella nostra
conoscenza e l'albero diventa un albero
verde dell'archetipo si stabilizza
artificial intelligence non è così
distante
intanto che cos'è perché l'hanno
definiti mille modi differenti ma prima
di tutto la artificial intelligence è un
software che il programma se stesso
migliorandosi costante noi come apprende
aprendo in funzione del dato del
contesto e dell'esperienza però i
sensori non sono così completi in e
artificialità jeans come nell'uomo noi
riusciamo a correggere il tiro
camminando con un odore con il sapore
con la vista l'udito per riuscire
intelligence ai sensori che gli
dall'uomo e quindi è limitata in questo
è limitata nel correggere in particolare
a un input e un output
quindi noi forniamo dei dati in ingresso
per esempio l'ingresso delle foto da una
videocamera
questi dati vengono elaborati e poi lei
restituisce un output per esempio si
dice che nella fotografia ci sono degli
alberi come si attua di solito si fa una
progettazione
dopodiché si fa una educazione fornendo
grandi quantità di dati e poi si
verifica che la food
se quello che è stato riconosciuto
dall'algoritmo sia coerente con quello
che gli abbiamo fornito davvero il
machine learning in particolare la parte
di artisti sull intelligence che si è
più diciamo affermata nel mercato ad
oggi e sistemi di interpretazione dei
grandi volumi di dati vanno a dare delle
raccomandazioni tramite machine learning
e 15 instradano verso una scelta una
soluzione
vi racconto due esempi simpaty solo nel
2017 quando samsung lanciò il galaxy s 8
gli smartphone sono tanti grandi
abilitatori della artificial
intelligence nelle tasche di tutti
dicevamo e samson aveva lanciato il
primo telefono che si sbloccava
riconoscendo la tua faccia
il problema è che nel marzo del 2010 17
stesso un loro cliente con un altro
telefono si è fatta di self l'ho messo
sopra il telefono e il telefono si è
sbloccata anche crisis management il
sistema subito è stato migliorato da
samsung ma c'è stato un team piccola
scivolata sul mercato apple molto fiera
pochi mesi dopo l'ansa quello che era
chiamato l'iphone in sé aveva una
feature una caratteristica che era
quella della stessa e dice riconoscere
la faccia e con grande precisione
sbloccare il telefono
il psd aveva un errore su un milione di
test quindi era abbastanza preciso
ebbene dopo pochi giorni dalla madre e
figlio si sono trovati una simpatica
scenetta la madre vieta al figlio di
giocare con il suo telefono nuovo che
era un iphone issami il figlio dicessi
ma ma poi prende telefono se lo punta in
faccia il telefono si sblocca anche la
madre plus cattivo in panico
torna la apple e diceva mio figlio mi ha
bloccato il telefono fanno tante prove
il risultato è stato che la apple si è
resa conto di un baco e ha dovuto
correggere l'algoritmo di riconoscimento
questi sono casi simpatici e molto lievi
sul danno che possano creare ma ci sono
dei danni molto più ampi e andato sui
giornali un problema che avuto amazon
con un software di riconoscimento dei
curriculum che candidati mandavano a
milioni presso la loro sede centrale
questo software di intelligenza
artificiale riconosceva con grande
precisione curriculum ma alla fine l'out
cam cioè quello che andava a generare
era suggerimento di candidati di sesso
maschile perché era stato educato con
grandi quantità di dati
che park che erano riferite a candidati
di sesso maschile quindi per
l'artificiale intelligence era normale
tra pari caratteristiche far vincere il
maschio amazon ha preso subito controllo
del problema spegnendo questo software
quindi quali sono le conseguenze delle
gag sono solo su questi temi non sono in
tutta industria mondiale tutta
l'industria mondiale la usa e per farvi
un esempio parto da un mestiere molto
semplice quello in taxista taxi driver
l'avete vista molto il taxista è un
mestiere di sviluppo globale
principalmente eseguito a livello
globale da maschi ed è ripetitivo
questi sono le caratteristiche del
taxista pochi anni fa sono nate delle
compagnie la più famosa e un corno
herbert che vanno a dare la possibilità
a chiunque possiede un mezzo e vuole
dare un passaggio con la sua macchina
qualcun altro di offrirlo
e chi ha bisogno di trovare questi
valorosi driver privati può farlo
tramite un'app il sistema combina
tramite l'intelligenza artificiale tante
richieste con tante offerte domanda e
offerta come huber si sono sviluppati di
sedili che fanno lo stesso si chiamano
compagnia di wright sharing e per darvi
un'idea di via la seconda e partecipate
per un bivio da apple team di apple l'ha
guardata molto da vicino perché perché
lo scorso anno molto 55.000 936 corse al
minuto soltanto in 5 e quello che è
successo e che la presidentessa di di è
andata a dire che andranno presto in
borsa e che si stima un valore intorno
ai 60 miliardi di dollari
perché questo valore così alto solo per
le corse che vendono perché hanno un
grande numero di clienti non solo per
questo anche grazie all'artista
l'intelligence che verrà usata nei
veicoli a guida autonoma i visi colia
guida autonoma infatti hanno una
caratteristica taglia non costo del
driver del pilota
quindi vanno a aumentare automaticamente
il margine ebitda della dell'inter
face.com per le auto guida autonoma si
stima che tra 10 15 anni si fermeranno
nel mercato e si affermeranno in modo
consolidato avranno anche delle parti
meccaniche meno per esempio non avranno
qui incontra meno produrlo e questo sarà
un grande onda di trasformazione nella
industria automobilistica per le auto di
massiccia nel 2020 si stima che la
artificial intelligence che il prossimo
anno eliminerà 1.8 milioni di posti di
lavoro sui lavori tipicamente ripetitivi
maschili maschili matri era 2.3 milioni
di nuove opportunità di lavoro per chi
partiamo da un problema della diversità
uomo donna nella ricerca del machine
learning abbiamo citato questa
tecnologia questa branca della iai che
oggi vede soltanto 12 per cento delle
donne impiegate c'è molto molto bisogno
di queste professionalità e le the
company's in particolare netflix amazon
che sono le compagnie al mondo con più
employment nella loro work force la loro
forza lavoro di sesso femminile non
arrivano neanche al 50 per cento netflix
la più performante al 47 per cento di
donne
amazon al 40 per cento di donne bene
tutte e due lavorano sui contenuti
netflix produce sapete video per
intrattenimento amazon propri prodotti
commerce che devono avere una cura del
contenuto alla descrizione il contenuto
molto precisa bene media d'entertainment
els che la sanità sono gli unici due
settori che hanno visto nel 2018 ricerca
mckinsey un aumento delle performance di
promozione ma femminili rispetto al
maschile
cioè le donne hanno performato meglio
degli uomini le uniche due industry ad
oggi
e questo perché accade perché la donna
per le sue caratteristiche è una
educatrice naturale è molto più impatti
che più compassionevole dell'uomo e
attenta alla gestione delle risorse è
sensibile nei confronti dei più deboli e
propende a donarsi stesse per la
prosecuzione della specie le conferme
sono che sempre stessa ricerca mckinsey
li prendo il cluster uk gran bretagna
dal 60 al 100 per cento le insegnanti
infermieri assistenti sociali addetti
alle paghe a delle assistenze clienti
amministrazioni delle risorse umane oggi
sono coperte da figure fini tutti ruoli
in cui l'artificio all'intelligence
signori non può fare nulla mentre la
donna ha scritto
in particolare uscito un libro
bellissimo di calcoli su ayane che
divide l'intelligenza umana di oggi in
quattro quadranti in alto a destra mette
quel intelligenza umana che ha bisogno
di empatia creatività strategia lì le
macchine non possono farci niente chi
sta in quella zona di solito sono
persone che hanno un grande potere
decisionale come per esempio gli
amministratori delegati
dopo il faccio qualche in basso a
sinistra l'intelligenza artificiale che
supplisce alla robotica e trasforma le
macchine in macchine autonoma e di fatto
e poi rimangono e quindi vi nel
quadrante massa sinistra quello blu
l'uomo non serve più e totale
automazione sono i due quadranti verdi
che si parla di aumenti intelligence
l'intelligenza aumentata in particolare
in basso a destra e intelligenza
aumentata per il design la produzione e
la creazione accelerata potenziata da
parte dell'uomo mentre in alto a
sinistra dove serve empatia e serve
ripetibilità e ottimizzazione el
artificial intelligence che elabora dati
grandissime quantità di dati da
suggerimenti all'uomo ma l'ultimo passo
viene lasciato all'uomo ed è proprio in
questo settore in alto a sinistra e
alcuni settori in cui le donne oggi sono
assolutamente leader insegnanti
infermiere lo dicevamo prima piuttosto
che consulenti di bellezza psicologia
hanno ormai conquistato e consolidata
statisticamente una predominanza mentre
invece stanno ormai raggiungendo la
parità dei sessi in basso a destra
ingegneri giornalisti senza di
programmatori architetti stanno
recuperando il gap verso i maschi le
donne molto in fretta proprio grazie a
queste nuove tecnologie duro abbiamo
detto che la capacità di apprendimento
di uomini e donne equivale servono più
donne nelle materie scientifiche e pensa
al modo in questo campo abbiamo detto
che le dinamiche di apprendimento umane
rispetto a quelle ea non sono così
distanti l'uomo al vantaggio dei sensi
ha più sensi da utilizzare abbiamo detto
che l'automazione e la artificial
intelligence sostituiranno i lavori
ripetitivi tipicamente maschili
abbiamo detto che c'è un enorme rischio
di amplificare by us e pregiudizi col
artificial intelligence l'esempio di
amazon e abbiamo una maggiore presenza
femminile nei ruoli che richiedono
empatia dunque artificial intelligence
sicuramente un'opportunità per la donna
ma come può la donna contribuire ad un
utilizzo più consapevole della
artificiali intelligence io propongo due
leve la prima leva è l'educazione
dobbiamo avvicinare le donne a lei ai
serve un'offerta formativa
se di carattere umanistico che creativo
che manageriale sistema che risulti
attrattiva per lei deve parlare la sua
lingua deve farlo a pensare in
particolare dovremo proiettare
nell'immaginario femminile la visione
dell'importanza della donna nel layout
si possono solo così condizionare le
scelte educative o dici
un esempio spettacolare è stato appena
lanciato a fine settembre dello scorso
anno in america nella iv high school
nelle scuole superiori americane hanno
lanciato questa iniziativa che si chiama
chicane stem e hanno portato come
testimonia le donne che ce l'hanno fatta
in tutte le grandi multinazionali
tecnologico microsoft aim oracle apple
eccetera rappresentando con il loro
volto e la breve descrizione di quello
che fanno all'interno delle scuole
un percorso di successo e quindi creando
il sogno sta ottenendo diversi successi
grazie al numero di iscrizioni che ha
ingenerato la seconda leva che
suggerisco è quella di applicare nuovi
modelli di change management delle
multinazionali
perché è proprio dalle corporation che
si può farsi bing che si può affermare
diffondere l'artificialità perché loro
hanno il potere finanziario e anche
attuativo per farlo ma come posso le
corporazioni indirizzare questo
cambiamento a guida femminile
considerando un dipartimento che oggi è
già consolidate che ha fatto dei passi
da gigante che è la gestione delle
risorse umane la gestione delle risorse
umane può essere impostata come modello
per una gestione delle risorse e ai
quindi creare dei dipartimenti su misura
per
alcune corporation che abbiano la
possibilità di curare l'artificialità il
gesù quanto vengono curati gli esseri
umani e in questi dipartimenti e
auspicabile che siano le donne a farla
da protagonista come già avviene nei
legge a romano dovranno vigilare il dato
il contesto è l'esperienza che dovranno
progettare educare e verificare
costantemente in ciclo continuo che le
artificial intelligence e rispettino
l'uomo che rispettino l'umanità che non
facciano amplificare i byas vero i
pregiudizi ma tu siano eque e quindi si
vuole sensibilità cura del dettaglio
empatia bene quindi quando le donne
parteciperanno quanto gli uomini nella
creazione educazione verifica della più
speciale intelligence a mio avviso
l'artificiale intelligence avrà un
maggiore rispetto per i bisogni e per
l'esistenza nell'essere umano
ancora una volta noi uomini abbiamo
bisogno delle donne è una grande
opportunità di ribilanciamento e oggi e
siamo molto determinati nel volerlo
grazie mille
[Applauso]